diego envío un correo electrónico en
cadena a sus amigos pidiéndoles que las
enviarán a más amigos el grupo de
personas que recibe el correo gana nueve
décimos de su tamaño cada tres semanas y
puede modelar se por una función p que
depende del tiempo y que vamos a digamos
a denotar conte y se mide en semanas
inicialmente diego envió el correo a 40
amigos escribe una función que modele al
grupo de personas que han recibido el
correo después de tres semanas desde que
diego envió la cadena y como siempre
trata trata de abordar este problema tú
solo porque bueno en unos momentos vamos
a tratar de hacerlo todos juntos
bueno en realidad como a mí me gusta
digamos abordar inicialmente este tipo
de problemas es elaborando una tabla una
tabla donde digamos del lado izquierdo
tengamos nuestra variable de la variable
t recordemos que mide el número de
semanas que han pasado desde que diego
envió su correo electrónico inicial y
tdt será la cantidad de personas que han
recibido ese correo verdad después de
estas este número de semanas entonces
pensemos si no han ocurrido digamos
ninguna semana estamos pensando justo en
el momento en que diego envía a su
correo inicial
sabemos que hay 40 personas que
recibieron ese correo electrónico verdad
aquí dice diego envió el correo a 40
amigos inicialmente que es lo que va a
pasar después bueno sabemos que la
cantidad de personas que reciben el
correo gana nueve décimos de su tamaño
cada tres semanas entonces podríamos ver
qué es lo que pasa cuando pasan
semanas verdad entonces después de tres
semanas vamos a tener nueve décimos más
de lo que ya teníamos verdad quiere
decir que tendríamos estas cuarenta
personas pero ahora vamos a tener nueve
décimas partes de esas 40 personas
verdad esto sí factor izamos el 40
verdad sería 40 que multiplica a 1 más 9
decimos verdad y 1 más 9 decimos también
lo podríamos simplemente reescribir como
1.9 verdad entonces 40 por 1.9 es el
número de personas que ya han recibido
ese correo electrónico después de tres
semanas verdad otra forma por ejemplo de
decir esto mismo es que la cantidad de
personas que han recibido el correo
electrónico crece un 90% cada tres
semanas verdad aquí está la cantidad de
personas que teníamos inicialmente más
el 90% de esas personas muy bien qué
pasaría si ahora dejamos pasar otras
tres semanas bueno en total tendríamos
seis semanas verdad y ahora tendríamos
un crecimiento del 90 por ciento de lo
que ya teníamos originalmente
originalmente tendríamos 40 por 1.9 y
luego multiplicamos por 1.9 verdad esto
es un crecimiento del 90 por ciento que
simplemente podemos reescribir como 40
por 1.9 al cuadrado que pasaría así otra
vez dejamos pasar tres semanas bueno
ahora tendríamos nueve semanas y nuestro
número número anterior tendríamos que
multiplicarlo por 1.9 entonces
tendríamos 40 por 1.9 al cuadrado por
1.9 nos da 40 por 1.9 al cubo verdad
entonces aquí claramente podemos ver que
esta función es exponencial tenemos una
cantidad
de 40 personas y nuestra razón común es
1.9 verdad cada tres semanas aumenta 1.9
entonces nuestra función pdte se
escribirá como 40 por 1.9 elevado al
número de periodos de tres semanas que
han ocurrido eso lo podemos medir como t
sobre tres verdad esto no se necesiten y
se miden semanas t dividido entre tres
nos cuenta cuántos periodos de tres
semanas han ocurrido verdad entonces por
ejemplo cuando te es igual a cero es
decir estamos en el tiempo inicial este
número estará elevado a la cero que es 1
y tendremos simplemente 40 cuando te sea
33 entre 3 es 1 claro porque sólo ha
ocurrido un periodo de tres semanas
verdad y tendremos 40 por 1.9 que es lo
que teníamos aquí cuando te sean seis
semanas seis entre tres son dos
claramente han ocurrido dos periodos de
tres semanas verdad y tendremos 40 por
1.9 elevado a las 6 entre 3 que es 2 que
es justamente lo que tenemos aquí y así
podríamos seguir adelante con digamos
con los distintos valores de t entonces
esta es nuestra función que nos ayuda a
modelar esa cantidad de personas